alors esteban c'était un enfant tout à
fait normal jusqu'à l'âge de 18 20 mois
on s'était rendu compte de rien et c'est
un enfant qui du jour au lendemain ses
rangs de fermer et l'a commencée a plus
joué avec son frère à être grognon à
crier quand il voulait quelque chose il
ya vraiment une espèce de cassure donc
on est allés chez le médecin pour
signaler sa elle nous a envoyé voir un
pédiatre centre hospitalier et on a fait
toutes les démarches pour un diagnostic
ts a donc cédé bilan un bilan
psychomoteur neuropsychiques ont baissé
banner est un enfant autiste sévère non
verbale on l'accueille actuelle pas on
la prend dans la gueule c'est c'est une
vie qui est chamboulée c'est c'est ces
trois jours les trois premiers jours
sans dormir sans manger a pleuré à se
dire pourquoi nous et puis ben il faut
avancer
moi j'ai dû arrêter de travailler je
travaillais dans la restauration et avec
des horaires assez atypique
donc c'était pas vraiment on pouvait pas
esteban c'est un enfant qui dort mais
puisque maintenant faire un peu mieux
il dormait deux à trois heures par nuit
donc quand vous avez trois heures de
sommeil
cinq à six rendez-vous de prise en
charge par semaine
un enfant qui va à l'école une
demi-heure par jour ben du coup je vois
pas trop comment j'aurais pu concilier
cela avec des horaires de restauration
sinon le quotidien c'est quoi basse et
s'est levé dodo promenade surtout pas
surtout pas de lieux publics ou
voilà des lieux qui pourraient pas ce
que parce que c'est des crises on part
on part dans des crises complètement
folle et puis et puis a le regard des
gens qu'est-ce qu'il est mal élevé sept
enfants il sait pas qui l'a handicapé
c'est pas qu'il autiste je suis même pas
sûr qu'ils sachent comment il s'appelle
mais au départ il faut faire le deuil
d'avoir un enfant dit normal et puis
d'après faut faire le deuil d'avoir une
vie normale
quand on ferme la porte de chez nous bat
on est tout seul avec notre enfant et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment le vivre pour
le comprendre
d'accord on se raccroche qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait je sais pas je les aime